So, I want to pick up at February 24, 1924, and this is volume 16.
I have a VIP on this one, but I'm getting to the stage now where I nearly have VIP on
the mall.
Just as Jesus deposited the whole law and the goods of redemption in his mother, so now
he wants to place, in Louisa, the foundation and the law of his eternal will.
And you, gospel, the gospel of the divine will, this is a very important statement.
So Louisa said, "I felt immersed in the divine will, and I thought to myself, 'Who knows
how many more things on his divine will?'
This is only volume 16, we're not even halfway through.
And she has no idea how much more is coming.
Who knows how many more things on his divine will?
My sweet Jesus will say to other souls, she still can't accept that she is the one.
If to me who am so unworthy and incapable he has said so many things, who knows how
many more sublime things he says to others who are more good.
And my loveable Jesus moving in my interior, which of course is Luke 1721, Kingdom of God
is within you, said to me, 'My daughter, the whole law and the goods of redemption were
written by me and deposited in the heart of my dear mother.'
It was right that since she was the first one who lived in my will and therefore drew
me from heaven and conceived me in her womb that she knew all the laws and that she would
be the depository.
Now this is what he's after, that she would be the depository of all the goods of redemption.
Now he's going to repeat over and over as we go on, he chooses one, he deposits everything
in this one, he completes the whole thing in this one, and then when that is done then
everybody else can take as much as they want, is that okay?
Some more, some less, but we're free to take what we want, but one person has to take the
whole thing.
So he's saying that our blessed mother was the depository of all the goods of redemption.
And of course she received the fullness of redemption in her Immaculate Conception.
And if she's the depository of all the goods of redemption you will understand therefore
that she's the mediatrix of all graces.
And when going out for my public life I manifested it to the people and to the apostles, I did
not add one comma, and not because I was incapable of it.
And the apostles themselves and the whole church have added nothing else to what I said
and did when I was upon the earth.
It's a very important statement, and all down the years the popes have said, you know, this
is the apostolic teaching, and this is how you apply it in this situation, in this modern
age.
But they're actually going back to the foundation to get it all.
The church has added no other gospel and instituted no additional sacrament.
Rather, she always turns to all that I myself did and said.
It's necessary that one who was called as the first received the foundation of all the
good which I want to do to all the human generations.
It's true that the church has commented on the gospel and has written much on all that
I said and did, as John says at the end of his gospel, if the whole world was full of
books we still wouldn't have done it all, and the whole world is full of books and we
still haven't done it all.
Okay.
It's true that the church has commented on the gospel and has written much on what
I did and said, but she has never moved away from my source.
That's terribly important.
And when you consider all the crises that have been in the church all down the centuries,
including our own, that is something that we can trust.
The church has never taught us anything wrong.
From the origin of my teachings is where she gets her stuff.
So it will be with my will.
I will place in you the foundation of the eternal law, my will.
That which is necessary so that it may be understood as well as the teachings which are
needed.
Now, beside that I want to give you Jeremiah 31, Jeremiah 31, verses 31 to 34.
This law will be written on your heart and you will come to the point where a neighbor
won't need to teach neighbor.
It'll be a wonderful day, wouldn't it?
And if the church will expand in explanations and commentaries, I put an exclamation mark
after that even I've added a commentary.
She will never depart from the origin, from the source constituted by me.
In other words, the foundation teaching is what we're actually reading in Louisa herself.
And if anybody wants to depart from it, he will remain without light and in obscure
darkness.
It's very interesting because Jesus keeps telling us that the divine will is light.
So if you depart from that into your own opinion or your own whatever, you've gone from the
light into your own darkness, that's a rather interesting one.
And an obscure darkness which means you're not going to understand anything.
And if he wants light, he will be forced to go back to the source, that is to my teachings.
And hearing this, Louisa said, my sweet love, when kings constitute laws, they call ministers
as witnesses of the laws in which they establish in order to place them in their hands, that
they may publish them and have the people's observe them, I'm not a minister, I love that.
Because I am so little and incapable and not good at anything.
And Jesus said, but I'm not like the kings of the earth who deal with the great.
Oh, isn't that interesting?
He doesn't deal with the great.
You know, Saint Paul says in one Corinthians chapter one that it's the weak things of
this world.
He chooses to confound the strong, okay?
So Jesus said, I'm not like the kings of the earth who deal with the great.
I love dealing with the little ones.
Now there's your Matthew 18 verses one to three.
Because the little ones are more docile, and they attribute nothing to themselves.
Whereas the great, you know, ring bells and celebrate their achievements.
But because of the little ones, everything is my goodness, he said.
But in spite of this, I too have chosen a minister of mine to assist you.
Watch this now.
She has resisted the priest for years, and she has wanted the priest to be removed.
And I was going to explain to her, now you know why he couldn't be removed.
I too have chosen a minister of mine to assist you in this state of yours.
And as much as you prayed me to free you from this daily, his daily coming, I did not listen
to you.
And even if you were no longer subject to falling back into that state, I will not permit you
to lack his assistance.
Now the most famous of these priest ministers is, of course, Hanebald of Lancia.
This was the reason for you to have one of my ministers, notice the Mai.
It's Jesus' law, it's Jesus' revelation, it's Jesus' charge, and it's his ministers
as well.
So I would put a ring around the Mai there.
But he might be aware of the law of my will, and knowing my teachings, that he would be
the witness and depository of a law so holy.
The interesting thing is that I think that position was St. Joseph in the redemption that
he was the witness to what God was doing in this incredible thing on the earth.
And as my faithful minister, he would publish in my church the great good that I want to
do to her by making my will known.
Now I don't like the her with the capital H, do you?
And the great good he wants to do in her is the church.
I don't think he should put a capital H there.
And of course you know that Hanebald of Lancia was the one who published the first ten volumes
and gave his imprometer to the first ten volumes, so he did in fact publish.
Then Louisa said, "I remain so immersed in the divine will that I felt as if I were swimming
inside of an immense sea.
My poor mind wandered about and I would take one drop of the divine will at some place,
another drop somewhere else, and the knowledge about it would pour so much into me that my
capacity was unable to receive at all."
And I said to myself, "How great, profound, high, immense, and holy is your will, O my
Jesus."
I think that's the most wonderful statement, isn't it?
How great, profound, high, immense, and holy is your will, O my Jesus.
You want to place that which regards your will altogether and I being little drown in
it.
Therefore, if you want me to understand that which you want to make me understand, infuse
it into me little by little.
Now, I've given you the answer to all your problems, okay?
In other words, you come up against something in these writings, you don't really understand,
you say, "Lord, infuse that knowledge into me."
But I would add and bring me to the point of actually living it.
Not only infuse the knowledge into me, but also bring me to the point of actually living
it.
And that means you take a mighty step forward in this journey.
In this way, I will be able to manifest it to the one who wants me to do it.
So she'll be able to manifest it to the priest.
And Jesus said, "My daughter, indeed, my will is immense."
Of course, it's infinite.
Or as Tony says, "Infinite, perfect, and eternal."
My will contains the whole of eternity.
If you knew the good which even one single word on my will and one single act done in
it by the creature contains, you would be stunned.
This is the bit we find, you know, we accept what we're being told, and we will do the
acts and everything.
We can't grasp the enormity of what we're actually doing.
And the Lord tries to say it to us from this angle and that angle and that angle and the
other angle as we go on in the writings.
That if we could comprehend what was actually going on, we'd be completely stunned.
In that act, the soul takes heaven and earth in her power.
My will is the life of everything and it flows everywhere.
So that's Psalm 139, "Where can I go from your spirit?
Where can I flee from your face if I go to the heavens?
You are there.
If I go into the depths of the sea, you are there," and so on.
My will is the life of everything and it flows everywhere.
And together with my will, she, that's the soul, flows within each affection, each heartbeat,
each thought and in all the rest that human beings do.
The incredible privilege of being able to influence the human race from within.
As far as I'm concerned, it's the only way to do it.
I think it's fantastic.
The soul flows within each act of her creator.
Look at that.
In every good that I do, in the light that I send to the intelligence, in the forgiveness
that I grant, in the love that I send, in the souls that I ignite with fervor and in
the blessed that I beatify.
In everything.
There is no good that I do nor any point of eternity in which she does not hold her little
spot.
I think that's fantastic.
There's a little place for you.
Now, the reason why I said your spot, it's John 14 verses 1 to 2.
There's a place for you as well.
I think that's fantastic.
You know how dear she is to me and how I feel her inseparable from me.
She is the true faithful one of my will.
Now, throughout the whole of the Old Testament, the struggle was to get people to be faithful
to the Lord, to be faithful to His will, to actually carry out His will upon the earth.
That's the whole struggle that's actually there.
And so the true faithful one, I think it's a fantastic thing.
She never leaves the divine will alone.
Therefore, run with it, Jesus said, and you will touch what I am telling you with your
own hand.
And that's an expression that you'll experience this yourself.
And as he was saying this, Louisa said, "I plunged into the immensity of His will, and
I ran and I ran."
But who can say everything?
I touched everything.
I flew everywhere, and I could touch what Jesus was telling me with my own hand.
But I am unable to put it on paper.
If Jesus wants it, He will give me more capacity, and so I'll stop here.
Now she has to revisit that, doesn't she?
Because in the end, she's got to say everything.
So one Corinthians 2.9, it's nearly impossible to say what has happened in this experience.
One Corinthians 2.9.
That's how you get things revisited, because Louisa puts her hand down and she says, "No,
not going.
I haven't got the words."
So February the 28th, 1924, all the goods which God has issued in creation in order
to give them to creatures are suspended in His will.
That's where we come along with our acts, okay?
Waiting for the human will to return to the original order.
This is the work He's doing in Louisa, the reordering of her will, and this is what precisely
He's doing in us, okay?
So while I was praying, Louisa said, "I felt my beloved Jesus within my interior," which
is your Luke 17.20, when you're getting used to that honor, aren't you?
At one point He's praying, or He is suffering, and sometimes He's actually working.
He called me very often by name, and I said to Him, "Jesus, what do you want?
What are you doing?"
It seems to me that you're very busy and that you suffer much, and while you call me
drawn by your occupations, you forget that you've called me and you don't tell me anything.
She doesn't let them away with anything either.
And Jesus said, "My daughter, I am very busy in you," this time He's not out in the world
dealing with all the stuff.
It's inside of her.
I am very busy, but it's in you.
For I am carrying out all the work of the living in my will.
He says, "You desire as I do it," he's doing all the work.
It's necessary that I first do it inside of you, and while I'm doing it, I bind all of
your interior to the unending light of my will.
There's a very important thing there because there are people doing an ovina of surrender,
and I wonder, what are they surrendering?
It's the whole of your interior, everything, absolutely everything.
And it isn't any harm to make a little list of what's actually inside of me, because I
could be keeping back something like I might give them one thing and not give them another.
And so because it's very unusual for a person to surrender the whole thing totally.
It's very unusual.
And so He said, "I'm working on each thing."
So the intellect, the memory, the will, the desires, the motivations, the thoughts, the
affections, the dista, that and the other, just to give you some idea of all the stuff
He's got to work in, and the whole lot of it has to be reordered, the whole out.
I don't know about you, but that's work, okay?
Because as we grow up, we develop a particular way of thinking and a particular way of responding
and all the rest of it.
The Lord has to reorder it all so that we are an exact image of Him, okay?
So I'm carrying out all the work of the living in my will.
It's necessary that I first do it in you.
And while I am doing it, I bind all of your interior, you see, in the on-ending light
of my will.
This means if I was to give you a sentence for it, it means that I will be spiritualized.
It's the first word you use.
And the second word you use is "divinized".
Spiritualized is the opposite of materialized, spiritualized, and divinized is the opposite
of humanized, sorry for the funny English words, but I just wanted to give you opposites.
Is that okay?
So that your little human will may be connected to the divine will and take its place in it.
And expanding within the divine will, it may receive all the good which the divine will
grants wants to give to the human will.
You must know that as the divinity decreed creation, it issued from itself everything
that it was to give to the creature.
We're going to stop there for a second.
That means everything he wants to give you and me is already given.
It's already paid for.
It's only a case of us collecting it.
Isn't that important?
It's really important to stop there just for a moment, okay?
It's only a case of collecting it because I often say to him, "You deserve it.
You paid for it."
Because if I pay for something I deserve to take it away, don't I?
Okay, he paid for it.
So let's just look at that again.
You must know that as the divinity decreed creation, it issued from itself everything
that it was to give to the creature.
The gifts, the graces, the caresses, the kisses, the love which it was to manifest to her.
And just as the divinity issued the sun, the stars, the Asia heavens and everything
else, so it issued all the gifts with which it was to enrich souls.
I think that really needs a little time to stop there and realize, excuse me for giving
it to you like this because it's Christmas, Santi has already got it in the bag.
It's only a case of you saying, "You wouldn't mind visiting my house, would you?"
I want what's in your bag.
Now to put it on a better level, you have the story of Mactimilian Colby at the age of
six and his mother had given him a spanking for which he'd get a jail sentence now and
told him he was incorrigible at the age of six.
And he walked all the way down to the church, walked straight up to a statue of our lady
and said, "My mother has given me up."
Our lady showed herself to him, "You know the story, don't you?"
I offered him two crowns, the guy is only six, he's just been written off and he discovered
he had a mother in heaven, which is rather useful.
And she offered him two crowns, one was the white crown of purity and holiness in the
priesthood and the other one was the red crown of martyrdom.
So this little fella who had been written off said, "I'll have the two of them."
In other words, if these are the gifts God has given to me, I'll have them all.
Now another person who said, "I'll have everything that you offer to me is St. Therese."
And there are others, I just can't name at this particular moment, but we just need
to realize that when you hear something like this, you have to say, "Lord, me too, I want
the whole package deal.
I don't care what's in it, even if it's martyrdom as well."
That's okay.
I'm saying yes to the whole package deal.
And when you say yes to the whole thing, you're opening a portal inside of yourself
for all of this to be actually poured into you.
And the Lord is saying, "Well, I'm having a good day because somebody's receiving what
I'm giving."
You see, we've got to take it out of just knowledge and into possession.
It's terribly important.
So Louisa continues, oh sorry, Jesus continues, "Now, as man withdrew from the Supreme Will,
he rejected all of these gifts."
Now, there's the tragedy of actually going back to the human will, and why you're told
in other messages that the human will is the prison of the soul and it's pure misery and
everything else, okay?
So notice that if the divine will leaves, he takes all his gifts.
I don't like that bit, do you?
So yes, we have to get him to stay forever, okay?
But the divinity did not withdraw from them, did not withdraw them into itself.
It left them suspended in its will, waiting for the human will to bind itself to the divine
will and to enter into the original order created.
So there's the divine will waiting for the true sons of God.
It's Romans 8, 19, because the true sons of God would be the ones that would re-enter
into the divine will and make reparation and substitute for the rest of humanity.
And therefore the humanity begins to let its human will go and let the divine will take
over.
So the divinity left all of these gifts suspended in its will, waiting for the human will to
bind itself to the divine will and to enter into the original order created by it.
That's the human will governed by the divine will.
So as to place all the gifts established by the Lord in current with the human nature,
in current is like that you have opened a postal service and the gift can come through
and be delivered.
So all the finances of love that kisses the caresses, the gifts, the communications and
my innocent amusements, which we have been reading about now for 16 volumes in Louisa,
which I was to have with Adam, had he not sinned, are suspended in my will.
So I want to give you Proverbs 8, 31.
God delights to be with the children of men.
Okay.
And of course the enjoyment that the Lord had with Adam is Genesis 3, 8.
We walked with Adam in the cool of the day.
And if you've ever been in Africa, everybody goes walking in the cool of the day.
You couldn't walk any other time.
So my will wants to onload from itself these piles of goods, that's why I'm thinking of
Santa Claus, these piles of goods, which it had established to give to creatures.
And this is why I want to establish the law of living in my will.
All the time he wants to give, give, give, give, he keeps saying that doesn't he?
Because love lives by giving.
And when we stop giving, love begins to die.
This is why I want to establish the law of living in my will, to place all of these suspended
goods in force between the Creator and the creature.
He's asking us to open a portal for all of these gifts to come back to humanity.
He's always thinking of the whole man, the whole of humanity, not just us as individuals.
And this is why, excuse me, and this is why I'm working in you to reorder your will with
the divine.
Now, the thing that fascinates me about this is that this is Volume 16.
And he's working this hard in Louisa.
I don't know what you'd have to do in me.
Considering the level of relationship that she has with the Lord, and the, the tolerant
of grace and gift is already given to her, that he's doing this level of work, it means
that there's an enormous amount he has to do in us, beyond anything we could imagine.
And we have to just sort of give him permission, yeah.
So it's to reorder your will with the divine.
In this way, I will be able to give the start and to place in current the many goods which
until now have been suspended between Creator and creature.
Okay.
I thought it's just come into my head and it's not from me.
Is that okay?
So I'll give it here.
He says it's a resurrection.
That's why he's got to recreate us.
It's like molecule by molecule.
That's why it's such hard work.
That's only, he's only just given to me that just this instant.
It's a, it's a resurrection for each one of us, which is a wonderful thing.
And you know from the gospel that very little space is given in the four gospels to the
resurrection of Jesus, all the space is given to the resurrection of the church, trying to
get Peter to rise from the dead, trying to get Mary of Magna to rise from the dead, trying
to get Thomas to rise from the dead, trying to get the 12 apostles to rise from the dead.
All the emphasis and all the work is to get the church to rise from the dead.
Jesus was nothing.
It was all over before anybody could even know what was happening.
And so this is the, the, the great work that's to go on in us.
Therefore, gradually we will be radically changed, radically changed, or as, it used
to be my favorite film on Christmas Eve, I haven't seen it for years, Ebenezer, Scrooge,
I'm not the man I was, I think it's a very wonderful statement, I'm not the man I was.
So there has to be a time when we look back and we realize, I'm not the person I was.
There's been radical change taking place inside of me.
So I'm working in you to reorder your will with the divine.
In this way, I will be able to give the start and to place in current, that means in the
whole church, in the whole world, the many goods which until now have been suspended
between the creator and the creature.
I so much care about this reordering of the human will with the divine and that the human
will live completely in the divine will.
Choose the completely, that's your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
You love the Lord with all your heart, all your soul, all your mind, and all your being,
not with bits of it.
To live completely in the divine will, that until I obtain this, I feel as if creation
has not had my primary purpose.
Besides, I created the creation not because I needed it.
This is terribly important, God doesn't need anything.
I was more than sufficiently happy in myself.
If I created it, it was because with all the goods we contained within ourselves, we wanted
an amusement outside of ourselves.
If I can use theology, it might think is funny, he wanted to make little gods outside.
Okay, that's Sam 8.
In case you think I'm really off, Lord what is man that you would even consider him, the
son of man that you would even have a thought for him, and yet you've made him little less
than a god with glory and honor you crowned him.
Also Sam 86, and I think it's verse 5, I said you are God's, all of you sons of the most
high, Sam 86, and I think it's verse 5.
If it's not, it's the one next to it.
So he said we wanted an amusement outside of ourselves.
And this is why everything was created.
And within an intense outpouring of our most pure love.
Now look, creation was made of most pure love, that Sam 1, 4, 5 verse 17, God only ever acts
out of love.
Therefore, when Satan comes along, what does he try to do?
He tries to destroy love.
He tries to turn it into something sick and sinful.
And when it becomes something sick and sinful, human nature is pulled down and destroyed and
family is destroyed, everything is destroyed.
Now since God is love, and God created everything out of most pure love, we are at our absolute
best when we reach pure love.
Now pure means not mixed with anything else.
Not mixed with selfishness, not mixed with worldliness, not mixed with personal gain,
not mixed with anything, pure love, then we're like him.
And we won't reach heaven until we reach that, because nothing can enter heaven that
isn't pure love, it has to be like him.
What comes back to him has got to be in the state in which it went out.
It went out in pure love, it's got to come back in pure love.
So that's why all of this purification has got to happen.
We issued the creature from our omnipotent breath, which of course is Genesis 2.7.
So that we might enjoy ourselves with him.
And he might be happy with us and with all the things created by us for love of him.
Now, the emphasis you get in these teachings is that God wants to enjoy his creatures.
I think one of the great joys of family is parents enjoying their children, isn't that
right?
And if you can't enjoy the children, you feel that you've been cheated.
And yet in all the teachings we've had all down the years, I've never heard a priest
ever tell us that God wanted to enjoy your company.
Isn't that amazing?
Never heard.
When I was young, we got this terrible image of God.
You're five minutes late from us and you go to hell.
And I used to go home and say, "What's wrong with him?"
Because my father wouldn't throw me out if I was five minutes late.
He might give out to me, but he wouldn't throw me out.
He wouldn't say I was fit for hell if I didn't jump to the moment.
So I used to say, "What was wrong with God?"
It wasn't what was wrong with God.
It was all around the preaching that we were getting.
And they never put across that God is joy and that God is happiness and God is peace.
And he wants to enjoy us and he wants us happy and peaceful.
And the first time I came across this kind of teaching, long before I met Louisa, I said,
"Lord, I got the impression this was only after the grave."
In other words, cold comfort.
He said, "No, they haven't told you the right thing.
It's for now.
You're supposed to have heaven on earth and then heaven afterwards as well."
It was really amazing.
That's why I want to just emphasize it here because he keeps on telling us that divine
will is pure joy.
He keeps on telling us that all happiness and all be attitude both in heaven and on
earth comes to the divine will.
And therefore, at some point we'll take it on board.
So when you're having your celebrations for Christmas, don't forget to invite him.
He likes to, Proverbs 8, 31, he enjoys being with the children of men, just as we all
enjoy being with family at Christmas.
So let's continue.
Now Jesus said, "As the one who was to serve only to make us rejoice and amuse ourselves
together," you see the partying is another word you could say.
And he very often tells Louisa that when she manages to do something in his will that he
really wants, he said, "Everybody's feasting in heaven."
So as the one who was to serve only to make us rejoice and be happy together, by withdrawing
from our will served us as bitterness.
And by moving away from us, instead of amusing himself with us, he amused himself with the
things created by us, now there's the origin of idolatry.
That you turn away from God as the author of all things to the things he actually made.
That's like saying, again keeping up the Christmas team, that you give a beautiful doll to a
little girl, okay, and instead of giving you the hug, she adores the doll.
The attention is on the wrong thing.
Instead of immediately saying, "Oh, Mom, oh Dad, thank you so much, you're wonderful."
Instead of turning back to the origin, they put their attention on the wrong thing.
And of course when the demon sees us putting our attention on the wrong thing, he sits on
your shoulders and says, "Keep going, this is the right direction."
And you end up in terrible idolatry.
So he amused himself with the things created by us, so the object of our love and attention
is wrong.
So love begins to be diverted from its purity.
Was not this destroying our purpose, he said?
And so Jesus is trying to say that if we turn from the origin of love and the origin of
life to anything else, that our standard is too low, our eyes are too low, and we will
be dragged down instead of lifted up.
Okay, so one of the major problems with attachments, which Jesus spoke about so much in volumes
one to four, and with idolatry, is that we turn away from our true source.
Now if you're driving on a motorway and you turn away while you're driving, you won't
reach your destiny, will you, you might die but you won't reach your destiny.
Now they're here and they're there.
Why?
Because you've taken your eyes off what it should have been.
And so another way that we would say this and we've said it in the past is all eyes
on Jesus.
Keep your eyes on the source.
That means you keep focused, your life is focused, or your compass is set as the pilots
will tell you, okay.
So he said, "Was this not turning the whole purpose of creation upside down?
That's what idolatry is, you turn God's entire plan upside down."
So see then how necessary it is that we restore our rights and that the creature return into
our womb so that we may begin our enjoyment again.
Now really what Jesus is talking about here, and at other times we would have called this
the war between flesh and spirit.
And the war between flesh and spirit is Galatians 6 verse 16 to 26, the war between flesh and
spirit.
And the demon wants you on the level of flesh because then he can grab you very easily and
pull you down further and further because the war between flesh and spirit.
So Jesus is trying to pull us up to where God wants us to be and the demon is trying
to pull us down.
And so Jesus says, "But man must return there where a man made our sorrow begin and he must
bind himself to our will with an indissolable bond."
That means permanent spiritual marriage.
Okay?
That's permanent spiritual marriage.
In other words, it's not just a temporary thing.
It's a true bond.
You see a bond is a contract and the word contract is used for covenant in the Bible.
So that's why I say it's a permanent spiritual marriage.
He must dismiss his own, that means his own will.
You need to add the word will in there and live of ours or we would say out of the divine
will.
The little word of by itself isn't sufficient.
So he must dismiss his own will and live out of our will.
That makes more sense, doesn't it?
So this is why I'm working in your soul and I want you to follow the work of your Jesus
who wants to place in current the gifts, the suspended graces which are there in my will
for every one of course.
Okay.
That's a very wonderful teaching but you need to take it slowly.
So March the 2nd, 1924, "By virtue of the light of the divine will, Jesus extended himself
to all creatures.
And so does the soul who lives in the divine will.
And so people in the divine will become the legitimate children."
That's your Romans 8, 19.
So Louisa said, "I was thinking of how it could be that as my sweet Jesus would think,
speak, operate, etcetera, he would extend his thoughts into each thought of the creature."
Now what Louisa is doing here is following up on the last message.
How do we do this practically?
So my beloved Jesus moving in my interior, which is your Luke 17, 21, told me, "My daughter,
there's nothing to be surprised about.
In me there was the divinity with the on ending light of its eternal will."
That's your 1 Timothy 6, 16.
God lives in unapproachable light.
So in me there was the divinity with the on ending light of its eternal will.
In this light I could see very easily each thought, word and heartbeat of all creatures.
So there you have the omniscience of God, he knows all things.
The omnipresence of God, he's present in all things, and the omnipotence of God, he can
do all things.
So I could see very easily each thought, word and heartbeat of creatures.
Now do you remember in the Gospel you're told very clearly in several places and I want
to give you Mark 2.8 and the healing of the paralytic is the example, but there are lots
of other examples as well that Jesus could read the thoughts of the men sitting in front
of him.
And the Gospel just says very clearly, reading their thoughts he said of what's going on
in your minds.
And he answers what's going on in their heads and they just said a word.
And this is what he's telling us that of course with his divinity he could see and
he could read all thoughts.
So I could see very clearly each thought, word and heartbeat and active creatures.
I think that must have made life extremely painful for Jesus during his lifetime.
I wouldn't like to know what was going on in everybody's heads would you?
And I wouldn't like to know what they were thinking of me while I was talking either.
And as I would think the light which I contained brought my thought to each thought of the
creature.
Now he's explaining this because he's going to say in our acts this is what he's enabling
us to do.
So as I would think the light of the divine will which I contained brought my thought
to each thought of the creatures.
And so with my word and with all the rest that I did and suffered, look the sun also
possesses this power.
Its light is just one thing or one reality.
And yet how many are not inundated by that light?
If the whole interior of man could be seen.
Now you know you have your list here, thoughts, heartbeats, affections are listed on top of
what you might have listed already.
Just as the sun invades everyone with its light, so would it make its light flow in
each thought each heartbeat and the like.
Now if the light of the sun can do this without the sun descending down below, down below
it means down on the earth from up high where it is 39,000 miles light years away.
No miles is it anyway.
To give its light and heat to each one.
And yet it is nothing other than the shadow of my light.
The sun is only a symbol of what God is himself.
So much more can I do it as I contain immense and endless light.
One John, one five, God is light.
Moreover, because my divine will contains this power, as the soul enters my volition
she opens the current, nowadays we would say opens a portal for divine light to come through
to everybody else.
So she opens the current of the light which my will contains.
In other words, we open a door or open a portal for that divine light to come through.
How important it is for every single one of us to be continuously fusing in the divine
will so that we are continuously keeping that door open so that life and grace and mercy
and everything will come to the human race.
And the more of us that do it, the more powerful it is, the door gets wider.
So the more she opens the current of the light which my will contains and my light invading
everyone.
See, that's why I say it's a portal to you.
You opened up for everybody brings to each one now notice God is interested in every single
soul.
Doesn't matter whether I like them or not, or I agree with them or not, doesn't matter
whether they're good religions or bad religions, whether doesn't matter what the condition
is, he wants the whole of humanity.
So when this light contains, sorry, when the soul opens the portal for this light which
my will contains and my light invading everyone, that's the universality of everything, brings
to each one the thought, the word, the act which have entered into this current of light.
Therefore, there's nothing more sublime, more extensive, more divine or more holy than
living in my will.
That's one of the very wonderful statements of this whole work.
Therefore, there's nothing more sublime, there's nothing more extensive, there's nothing more
divine, there's nothing more holy than living in my will.
The generations of the divine will acts are incalculable.
Now you know generations are generations upon generations upon generations upon generations.
So when the soul is not united with my will, nor enters into it, she neither does her little
round nor opens the current of its unending light.
Therefore, everything she does remains personal and individual.
Her good, her prayer, are like the little light that's used inside of rooms, in other
words, candles, which have no power to give light to all the storage places in the house
and even less can it give light outside.
And if oil is lacking because they use tiny little oil lamps, you know what I mean?
That is the continuation of her acts, the little light is extinguished and remains in
the dark.
Notice the oil for the lamp as the continuous acts.
Jesus continues, "Then I was fusing myself into the eternal divine volition, placing myself
ahead of everybody," why is she ahead of everybody, because she's the first to do this.
In order to bring to the divine majesty as first among all, all the acts of creatures,
the return of everything and the love of all creatures.
But while I was doing this, I thought to myself, how can it be that I go ahead of everyone
when I was born after so many generations?
I love that she's in the middle of an act and then she gets a thought that needs to be
fixed.
I just love it, it sounds awfully like me.
At the most, I should place myself in the middle between the past and the future generations
which will come, or rather because of my own words in this, I should place myself last
and behind everybody.
My beloved Jesus, moving in my interior, there's your Luke 17, 21, said, "My daughter, the
whole of creation was created so that all look at the A double L would do my will."
In other words, the whole of man, the whole of creation is just one man, we're all just
part of Adam.
The very life of creatures was to flow within my will like the blood flows in the veins,
which of course was the pre-fall position.
They were to live in the divine will as my true children, which is your Romans 8, 19.
Everything was to be foreign to them of all that belonged to me, just as children growing
up with you in your house, nothing in your house is foreign to them.
I was to be their tender and loving father.
This is the Abba of the Bible, the tender loving father.
And they were to be my tender loving children.
Now that's Psalm 103, as a father loves his children, I think it goes from verse 45, I
wouldn't be completely certain on the verse.
As tenderly as a father loves his children, so the Lord loves those who fear him.
So in the messages leading up to this, the emphasis was on the joy and the happiness
that was to be celebrated between God and humanity.
Now you have this loving relationship being emphasized here.
And notice it's tender and loving.
So you can see the disaster of the Lord having to send chastisement when he wants to be a
tender and loving father.
Now since this was the purpose of creation, even though there have been other generations
before, this doesn't say anything, they will be placed behind and my will will place as
first the ones who will be and who have been faithful in maintaining intact the purpose
for which they were created.
In other words, the ones who actually live in the divine will.
These whether they have come before or later will occupy the first order before the divinity.
By having maintained the purpose of creation, they will be distinguished among all and marked
with the halo of our will.
That's interesting.
And this halo will be like a refulgent gem and everyone will let them pass freely so that
they may occupy the first place of honor.
So I want to give you a first place of honor text, Luke 9, 46 to 48.
Mark 9, 35.
And Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 9.
So what the Lord is going to do now is give us two examples of what he has just been saying.
And this is the model for us in our teaching that you give the teaching, then you give
some examples.
So there's nothing to be surprised about, Jesus said.
The same thing happens in this low world.
I love the expression.
This is earth.
Imagine a king in the midst of his court with ministers and deputies and armies around
him.
Then his little prince son comes in.
And even though all these others are great, who does not give free access to the little
prince who may take his place of honor beside the king, his father?
Who interacts with the king with that familiarity which is worthy of a son?
Who would blame this king and this son because even though the son is the littlest of all,
he rises above all of them and takes his primary and legitimate place close to the king,
his father?
Certainly no one.
On the contrary, all would respect the right of the little prince.
Okay.
Now, before we leave that, another example, Saint Teresa of Lesus, who is the little child
of the Lord, was asked, would she be afraid of God's judgment on the day of judgment?
She said, "No, I'll be sitting on his knee."
She said, "No, I'll be sitting on his knee while he's judging the world."
Yes, your little prince, or princess.
So the second example he gives as a family, descend even lower, he said, imagine a family.
A son is born first, but he didn't want to occupy himself between the will of his father.
Nor did he want to study or work.
He remained almost moronic in his sleuth, forming the sorrow of his father.
Then another son comes to the light, and this one, though more little, does the will
of the father.
Studies and arrives at becoming a professor worthy of occupying the highest positions.
Now, who is first in the family?
Who receives the place of honor close to the father?
Is it perhaps not the one who came last?
Now the Bible loves giving examples of the fact that the last is first and the first
or last.
And rarely do you see, if I can put it this way, the right one inheriting the throne.
It's always the one you're not expecting.
So my daughter, not only those who will have preserved intact within themselves the purpose
of creation will be my true legitimate children.
Now notice who the true legitimate children are, the ones who preserve intact the purpose
of creation.
So I want to give you Matthew 19, 30 for that example for the family.
By doing my will, they have preserved within themselves the pure blood.
Now notice the pure.
It's not mixed with anything else.
The pure blood of their celestial father, who has given them all the features of his
likeness.
That's two Corinthians 3, 18.
You become like that which you worship.
And therefore it will be very easy to recognize them as our legitimate children.
Our will will preserve them noble, pure, fresh.
I love the fresh.
That means that it's always a new day, it's always a new creation.
As far as God is concerned, you're starting today.
So you don't have this stale thing, oh, I've heard that all before, you know.
So our will will preserve them noble, pure, fresh.
All love, because we mentioned it many times that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine
will and love for the one who created them.
All love for the one who created them.
So that all love for the one who created them is your Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
And also John 15, 9.
As the father has loved me, so I have loved you and so you are to love one another and
so on.
Everything is love.
As our children who have always been in our will and who have never given life to their
own will, they will be as though the first to be created by us, giving us the glory and
the honor of the purpose for which all things were created.
This is why the world cannot end.
Very important because so many people are saying we're seeing all the signs at the end
of the world.
We're seeing all the signs of a new era, an old era dying and a new era coming.
This is why the world cannot end.
We are waiting for the generation of our children who by living in our will will give
us the glory of our works.
These will have our will alone as their life.
It will be so very natural for them to do the divine will.
Isn't that something?
It will be spontaneous.
It will be effortless.
This is natural as the heartbeat, the breathing and the blood circulation.
They will not keep it as law because laws are for rebels, but they will keep it as their
life and as honor as the beginning and as the end.
Therefore, my daughter, may you take the heart, my will alone, and be concerned for
nothing else.
If you want your Jesus to fulfill in you and enclose in you the purpose of the whole
of creation.
It's the most wonderful text.
March 13, 1924, true love can hide nothing from the beloved and the divine will is most
pure light.
Light and love.
God is God, God is light and God is love.
So it's one, John, one, five, and one, John, four, seven.
And the verse is coming after it.
Louisa said, "I felt my said dying because of the privation of my beloved Jesus."
And after much struggling, he moved in my interior, Luke 1721, and he shared his pains
with me.
Now I want you to notice in this particular text, everything has now become interior.
All the sufferings are interior.
Before she used to have them exterior, it's now all gone interior.
So he moved in my interior and he shared his pains with me.
But so much that I felt I was suffocating.
I felt the rattle of agony, and yet I myself am unable to tell who was the cause of my
pains.
You see, this is nothing to do with the exterior anymore.
She's shifted into a higher plane altogether.
So the pains on an interior level in the divine will are divine pains.
She's going to get the words after a while.
See I felt I was within an immense light, one Timothy 616.
I was within an immense light, and this light changed into pain for me.
That's very interesting.
It changed into pain.
Then after I had somehow suffered, notice somehow suffered because she identifies suffering
as in the body.
My beloved Jesus told me, "My daughter, this is why I did not want to come."
Because the pains I was suffering were so many, and in coming to you, my faithful one, who
is inseparable from me, like the Blessed Mother now.
My love would have led me to share them with you, and I seeing you suffer would have suffered
in seeing you suffer because of me.
And Louisa said, "Am I, Jesus, how you've changed?"
It shows that you no longer want to suffer together with me, and she's missed the point
altogether.
You want to do it on your own.
After all, if I am no longer worthy to suffer together with you, do not hide yourself but
come without making me suffer, so you must come anyway.
It's true that not sharing in your pains will be a nail to piercing for me.
She's beginning to somehow intuit, it's all going to be interior pain from here on in.
Now he's been gradually leading her in that direction with all the privations.
"But it will still be less painful than your privation," she said.
"Jesus said, 'My daughter, you do not know the nature of true love.'"
And this is why you speak like this.
True love can hide nothing from the beloved, neither joys nor pains.
Even for one sorrowful thought, for one fiber of the heart which it hides and does not pour
into the beloved, it feels as though separated from her.
It feels discontent and restless.
And until it pours its whole heart into the beloved one, it can't find rest.
So coming and not pouring my whole heart into you, and also my pains, my joys and the ingratitude
of men, will be too hard for me.
I've tried to put that in English, is that okay?
I would content myself with remaining as though hidden in the depth of your soul rather than
coming and not sharing with you my pains and my most intimate secrets.
Therefore, I will content myself with suffering and seeing you suffer rather than not pouring
my whole heart into you.
So if she's inseparable from him and he's receiving all this terrible stuff from earth,
she's going to feel it.
So she doesn't need nails, she doesn't need a crown, she doesn't need a carrying of the
cross.
She doesn't need the crucifixion, it's all interior.
And so she begins to appreciate the interior passion of Jesus, which she shares with us
in the hours of the passion.
So Jesus is going to give her a wonderful revelation here.
Jesus said, "My Jesus, forgive me, I said this because you said that you suffered and seeing me suffer,
but may it never be that there be anything which may separate us in love.
Rather, any pain but separated never."
And Jesus added, "Do not fear my daughter, wherever my will is, there cannot be separation
in love."
Now, I want to connect that with 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, the fifth and sixth line at the beginning
of this message.
I felt I was within an immense light and this light changed into pain from a, Jesus is trying
to explain that to her.
Do you see that statement?
So what I do is I try to connect them with an arrow so that I don't miss it.
Is that okay?
So he's trying to explain to her that now that she's in this inseparable position with
him, naturally, if he has something, she's going to have it as well.
So Jesus said, "Do not fear my daughter, wherever my will is, there cannot be separation
in love.
In fact, I did not do anything to you.
It was the light of my will that made you suffer, now do you see it?
I was within an immense light and it changed into pain for me."
So he's trying to explain to her what she's actually experiencing, penetrating into you
like most pure light, my will brought my pains deep into the most, in most fibres of your
heart.
My will is more piercing than any iron.
Why did you say any iron because in the ancient world, iron was one of the things that people
used for weaponry and for swords and all that kind of stuff.
So my will is more piercing than any iron, more than nails, thorns and lashes.
In other words, you will suffer more or not less.
Using most pure light, in its immensity, it sees and it encloses everything, therefore
it contains the power of all pains.
And as it makes its light penetrate into the soul, it brings the pains that the divine
will wants.
So since your will and mine are one, the current of the divine light brought you my
pains.
This is how my divine will operate in my humanity.
Its most pure light brought me pains at each breath, at each heartbeat and each movement.
This is the revelation of the interior, the passion of Jesus that went on his whole life.
So its most pure light brought me pains at each breath, each heartbeat and each movement
into my whole person.
I mean, that's unimaginable for me, I don't know about you.
Nothing was hidden from it, either what was needed in order to restore the glory of the
Father on the part of creatures or their offenses, or what was needed in order to save them.
Therefore it spared me nothing.
Its most pure light crucified my most intimate fibers.
Now Louisa tries to give that to us piecemeal in the hours of the passion.
Its most pure light crucified my most intimate fibers, my heartbeats of fire.
Because love when it reaches a certain level actually ignites.
Even St. Therese of this you said that she experienced love as fire inside her.
And so the divine will, made of me, they continual crucified.
Now there is a new title for Jesus.
The continual crucified.
And not only in my hands and feet, but its light scanning me thoroughly.
Now I got a little shiver when I was looking at that.
Because you know the scan doesn't miss anything, it's not meant to miss anything is it?
And you know if the doctor doesn't know what's wrong with you, he says we'll try to scan.
Then you're in trouble.
And so if the Lord scans me completely, I'm in real trouble, I don't know about you.
Because he's not going to miss anything.
And he says one heartbeat, one fiber.
He gets right, he can see absolutely everything in our desires and our motivations and everything.
So it's really better to let him do the scanning and get on with it.
Instead of thinking there's a hole where I can hide, because that actually isn't.
If creatures knew what my divine, where am I, oh yeah.
So it made me the continual crucified and not only in my hands and feet, but its light
scanning me thoroughly crucified the tiniest particles of my person.
That's why when you allow yourself to get into deep prayer, you'll notice that some
kind of a spot has been touched and it has got to be got rid of.
You mightn't even have a name for this spot, do you know what I mean?
It's the scan saying, uh oh, shift.
That's why prayer mightn't be comfortable all the time.
And it shouldn't be if the scanning is going on.
But I'd rather be scanned now than later, don't know about you.
If creatures knew what my divine will made my humanity suffer for love of them, they
would be drawn to love me as by a powerful magnet.
That's absolutely true.
But for now, they cannot because their taste is rough.
The word taste is used here to sort of what they want, their desires.
And they are profaned by the human will.
In other words, they're wanting the wrong things.
And they would not enjoy the sweet fruits of the pains of my divine will.
Or so, since living at the low level of the human will, please look at the low level.
They would not even understand the height, the power, the attitude, the goods which the
divine will contains.
They wouldn't have a clue what you're talking about.
But the time has come, this is for the new era, the time has come when the supreme will
making its way into the midst of creatures and making itself understood more.
You see, it takes time to understand it completely in so far as you can.
Will manifest the pains of my eternal will, that the eternal will made my humanity suffer.
We'll get that in the hours of the Passion.
Therefore, when the light of my will flows within you, let yourself be scanned.
Don't resist.
Let yourself be scanned by it.
That it may accomplish its perfect and full or complete work in you.
In other words, the divine will once saints.
At one stage in my life, I might repeat it again if I ever get time.
I did a historical study of the church and did a huge big graph.
I don't know how ever happened with my graph.
One of the things that amazed me was that at every crisis in the church, the Lord answered
it by a crop of saints.
Every single one of them.
So today, it's the divine will saints is after.
The Lord doesn't want anything less.
So you may as well let him do the scanning.
And if you do not see me often, Jesus said, do not afflict yourself.
These are the new events which we, the divine persons, are preparing and unexpected things
for the poor world.
What the light of my will will never be lacking to you.
After this, my beloved Jesus disappeared and I felt as though immersed deep inside His will.
I felt my poor littleness in contact with the divine greatness.
That's the I am not flowing in the I am, the nothingness in the allness.
So I felt my poor littleness in contact with the divine greatness, height and immensity.
My misery touched by divine riches, my ugliness touched by eternal beauty, isn't that magnificent?
In His will, I lived out of the reflections of God.
That's your two Corinthians 3, 18.
And while receiving everything from Him, I found everything and I carried the whole of
creation is though on my lap to the feet of the eternal majesty.
Now in that position, you are receiving everything, not just for yourself but for everybody else.
And it wouldn't make sense not to pass it on to the whole of creation and bring the
whole of creation back with you.
That's the process that has got to happen.
It seems to me that in His will, I did nothing but ascend to heaven and descend upon the earth.
And that's John 1.51, the letter.
I did nothing but ascend to heaven and descend upon the earth to then ascend again in order
to carry all the generations, to love Him for everybody and to have Him loved by all.
Then while I was doing this, my Jesus made Himself seen again and told me, my daughter,
how beautiful and delightful it is to see the creature live in our will.
She lives out of our reflections and while living out of our reflections, she absorbs
into herself the likeness of her Creator.
So she is embellished, rich, expanded so much as to be able to take everyone and bring everything
to us.
Now notice that while living in the divine will, you don't pray for yourself at all.
The Lord embellishes and riches get you to move on and sanctifies you and absolutely
everything else.
It's His work.
That's what He does.
And so we'd only be spoiling it and I said, "Well, I'd prefer red if you wouldn't mind
when He knows some other color is the right color for you."
So we'd only be messing it up.
You see, Ephesians 2, 10, we are God's work of art.
Now the canvas can't say to the painter, "Do you mind?
I don't like that color."
Because the painter might be using a dull color at that particular moment.
But if you look at the picture on the wall down there, the dark colors were absolutely
essential for the bright colors to be seen.
And so we have to let the Lord choose, and sometimes it's trials, sometimes it's pains,
sometimes it's joys, sometimes it's happiness.
We just don't know the colors and the paints that He's actually using.
But He's working away on us while we're working away trying to give Him the glory and praise
and bring humanity back to Him.
So she is embellished, she is enriched, she's expanded so much as to be able to take everyone.
I love the everyone and everything to us.
And she draws so much love from us as to be able to love us for all.
Now to me, that's John 7, 37 to 39, that Jesus said, "If you come and you really drink
from me out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water."
And we, that is the three divine persons, find everything in her.
All our love issued in creation, our satisfaction, our contentment, and the return of our works.
Our love towards the soul who lives in our will is such and so great that what we are
by nature, the soul, becomes by virtue of our will.
There's your Sam 86, and I think it's verse 5 again.
I said, "You are God's, all of you sons of the Most High, and it's also your Sam 8.
You've made us little less than a God with glory and honor you crowned us, giving us
power over the works of your hands."
So what we are by nature, Jesus said, the soul becomes by virtue of our will.
We pour everything into her.
Not even one fiber of hers do we leave out which is not filled with what is ours.
We fill her so much to the point of overflowing, forming divine rivers and seas around her.
And into these seas we descend and enjoy ourselves.
And we admire our works of love, feeling fully glorified.
Therefore, my daughter, live in the most pure light of my will.
If you want your Jesus to repeat again that word which he spoke in creating man by virtue
of our will, let us make this soul in our image and likeness.
You can call it resurrection and you can call it recreation.
We're being remade.
So I'm going to stop there for tonight.